- Take a step back and
understand what you're doing
with yourself.
What makes you happy?
Are you trying to be rich
because you wanna stick it
to your parents or
everybody else that said
that you couldn't?
Or are you trying to do something
'cause you actually like it?
Are you trying to be rich
because you wanna go buy shit
to create a perception that you're happy?
Or do you actually want to be happy?
- Yeah!
- You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
So listen, I think there's two core things
that I wanna think about,
which is, there's a lot of ways I say it,
macro, micro, perspective and execution.
When I think about why the 9,000 of you
would allocate time and
money to come to an event,
it means that there is a need
for offense, more offense,
getting out of defense, offense.
To me, this is about one big conversation.
(laughing and cheering)
One big conversation of what
are we actually doing here?
And so, for me, when I think
about what are we actually
doing here, the first thing
that always comes to mind,
and I know some of you
have heard this from me,
but the fact that the odds
of being a human being
are 400 trillion to one is
something that I struggle with
not thinking about
almost on a daily basis.
I genuinely believe that every person
in this arena right now, including myself,
disproportionately aren't
understanding how fortunate
we are to have a life.
There is literally nothing,
there's literally nothing
that you will ever accomplish, ever,
that is more ridiculous than
the fact that you were even
given a life in the first place.
The fact that your mom could've got up
and got another glass of wine,
(laughing)
and that would result
in you not being here,
or a human, blows my mind.
And so, for me, one of the
things that I clearly am
is optimistic and positive,
but I'm disproportionately practical.
The great fortune of my
life was that I was born
in the Soviet Union and I came to America,
and my parents were poor and
we lived in a studio apartment
with multiple family members,
and I wasn't given anything,
and I genuinely believe the biggest issue
for so many people in today's
world to get to happiness,
forget about how you
define success from a money
or a business standpoint,
is I just think most people are entitled.
I think that most people are entitled
and genuinely believe that
they deserve something,
and I think when you come from zero
and you come from such a nasty
place, like Soviet Russia,
the framework that I was brought up in
was lack of entitlement,
nobody owes you shit,
and if you wanna accomplish something,
you've gotta do something about it.
And, for me...
(cheering)
Because let me promise
you something right now,
if you look to the left and right of you,
like, no matter what your
problems or short comings
or lack of opportunities are,
the person to the left and
right of you has their own life
and aren't worried about your dumb shit
'cause they've got their own dumb shit.
And so, for me, my mom, basically,
'cause my dad worked every hour
so I didn't really even know
him until I started working
in the liquor store as a teenager,
my mom's lack of interest in any excuse
created a framework for me.
So, for me, what's interesting about that
is that made me positive, not negative.
What's amazing about being
in a place where you realize
nothing is entitled is
you get into a place
of full accountability.
Genuinely, I believe that
every problem I have,
I run a 1,000 person, $200
million marketing company,
Vana Media, and literally,
every single problem
in that company, and let me promise you,
there's 40,000 fucking
problems right this second
as I'm on this stage,
every one of those problems are my fault
because instead of what I watch
so many people do and say,
oh, fucking Susan's fucking up,
I realize that I'm the
fuck-face that hired Susan.
(laughing and applauding)
My friends, I'm coming out the gate here
with a very important framework,
which is, I promise you
that the second that you
stop dwelling, stop worrying about shit
that you cannot control,
start realizing that everything
fucked up is your fault,
you actually get ridiculously
happy, not upset.
(cheering and applauding)
I mean it, I mean it.
Now, just to make sure
there's no confusion,
you're talking to somebody
who was a Jewish guy
born in the formal Soviet Union,
where both my grandfathers went to jail.
One for a decade, one for two
years, 'cause he was Jewish.
So, I'm not talking about there isn't shit
that needs to be overcome,
I'm not saying that shit isn't fucked up,
I'm saying that if you
cry about it 24/7, 365,
nothing's gonna happen.
And so in that framework, here's my point.
If there's any confusion
to the following statement,
there's a very significant
chance that you won't go
to the place you want to, which is,
this thing right here
should fuck with your mind
like you can't imagine.
This computer that I'm holding in my hand
is literally more
powerful than the computer
that President Reagan had
to run the Free World.
This computer in my hand
is connected to an internet
that doesn't know who you
are or where you came from
or what you're up to.
The platforms on it, Facebook
and Instagram and LinkedIn
and Twitter and Podcasting and YouTube,
they don't care where you came from,
who your grand-pappy was,
what you did yesterday,
they're unemotional platforms
that every person in this room
can go on and start building
something for themselves,
and the cost is zero.
(cheering and applauding)
One of the reasons that
I like to remind people
that the cost is zero is that,
I don't know if you know,
but when Facebook's
reach started to decline,
or when Instagram changes its algorithm,
people actually complain
and are fucking pissed.
And I try to remind them
that the platform is free.
(laughing)
They're like, Facebook's fucking me up.
I'm like, it's free, dick.
(laughing)
Why did Instagram, I lost followers,
Instagram cleaned up their shit.
It's free, asshole.
We...
Whether you have too much,
and there's plenty of
people who have too much,
and whether you have too little,
and everybody in between,
in 2019, especially in America,
we are on full complain mode,
and that is the opportunity.
If I can do anything in this room today,
get one person of the 9,000
that came in here dwelling
and complaining and
thinking shit's fucked up,
and actually get them to realize
that is 100% the framework
of how they see the world,
and, literally, if they just changed that
and start actually doing.
If I can accomplish that,
waking up at three fucking 45
in the morning this morning was worth it,
and that is my agenda.
(cheering and applauding)
Because what I'm about to
talk about for the next
25, 30 minutes is execution.
I'm gonna talk to you about
why I think Instagram ads
are so underpriced,
that whether you're selling real estate,
or you're a financial advisor,
or you wanna sell T-shirts,
or you wanna sell yogurt,
or you wanna be a comedian, a rapper,
like, it's so underpriced.
Instagram has the collective
attention of the far majority
of our country.
Instagram Story ads are so underpriced
that even if you put content
that's average in it,
it's over performing.
This is exactly what happened
on Google in 2001 to 2005.
It's exactly what happened on
Facebook from 2009 to 2012.
When our collective attention
is in one place at scale,
and we're actually consuming,
and the ads haven't gotten
money yet from BMW and Nike
and Pepsi and Coca-Cola, to
make the ad prices go up,
us entrepreneurs and
individuals have to strike,
just like buying beachfront
property in Malibu
before people realized it was Malibu.
I day trade attention, that's
what I do for a living.
I spend all my time trying to figure out
where there's attention,
and then I try to figure out
how to run media ads and
how to create content
for those channels.
I am agnostic, I do not
care about social media,
I don't care about Facebook,
I don't care about Instagram,
I don't care about Twitter,
I care about your collective attention.
Whether it's on this stage right now,
whether it's the content that I make,
whether it's getting ridiculous
seats at WrestleMania
so I show up on every fucking 15 minutes,
whatever it is, I'm interested
in where the attention is
and how do I penetrate it, understand?
What happens next is
the most important part.
I've got your attention
for these 40 minutes,
but if this keynote sucks, I lose.
I've got your attention on LinkedIn,
I post that on LinkedIn,
guys, my last book, it's not up here,
my last book, Crushing It!, I
wrote about the most important
platforms in the world,
to produce content on,
I didn't even put LinkedIn in it.
Literally, only 24 months ago,
when I was writing the book,
I didn't even put LinkedIn in the book
to talk about the value of
LinkedIn for us entrepreneurs
and individuals.
Today, as I stand here right now,
I would argue that LinkedIn
might be the platform
that I'm most excited for
everybody here to go home
and go produce content for.
And I don't mean go spam
people and send them messages,
I mean posting content.
And it could be about fitness,
it could be about orange juice,
it could be about anything.
LinkedIn, today, on this day,
is acting more like
Facebook did four years ago
than Facebook does today.
The amount of organic reach
you get, without paying for it,
is so remarkable, it's unbelievable.
Yet, we live in a world
of headline readers
verses practitioners.
I produce content daily.
I just replied to a
comment to somebody that's
in the audience here 'cause
they were pumped, (man cheers)
not you because it was
a lady and you're dude,
but you might've been an
hour ago or, you were,
oh, you were, I DM'd you back.
I DM'd you back, but
there's some lady here.
Like, I'm in the trenches,
I'm not sitting in the ivory tower,
I talk about this content
daily 'cause I do it
and I live it, you're talking to somebody.
I wanna remind everybody,
everybody starts with zero followers.
I wanna remind everybody
that everybody starts
with zero followers.
In 2007, when Twitter hit the scene,
I spent six, seven, eight hours a day
between 7:00 p.m. and 2:00 in the morning
going on Twitter and replying
to every single person
that mentioned anything about
wine for six hours a day,
for four years, and still,
nobody knew who the fuck I was.
So when I hear people put
out three posts on LinkedIn
after a keynote like
this and then email me
and say, hey Gary V, loved
you in Chicago, great talk,
but gotta tell you, you're wrong.
And I reply, what happened?
Well, I posted on LinkedIn
and nothing good is happening.
And then I ask, how
long you been doing it?
They're like, well, I've posted twice
for the last two weeks.
And I reply, you're a fucking asshole.
(laughing)
I just looked at a student like,
you know when you can feel?
Like, how is anybody
confused that it takes,
let me say it very slowly,
an obnoxious amount of work
to create any level of success.
There is so much confusion in the system
about the amount of work
ethic that needs to be ployed
to actually have success.
Let me tell you this, anybody
you've ever met that made it,
worked their fucking face off.
You know people that are rich that didn't,
they inherited it, but
they didn't make it.
And the confusion of the one
or two stories you hear about
when it happened fast,
like Instagram or Facebook,
has confused everybody.
And the amount of excuses
we put into the system
so that we don't have to
do that work is remarkable.
What's interesting is, the
reason I have such a good
framework on this is because
I'm one of the great,
all-time worst students in
the history of this country.
I mean it.
I literally never opened
a book in high school,
did all my Scantron test
C, B, C, B, A, C, B, A.
If there's any kids in the crowds,
I'm gonna give you a real
good secret if you're
in public schools, they
just push you through.
The reason I watch people
live for the weekend
and love Friday like it's
the greatest shit ever
because they hate their
Monday through Friday
so fucking much,
the reason I hear the system's
broke, my boss is a dick,
it doesn't work for me, I'm not from that,
it's just excuses not to do it.
It's the same shit I did
from 1st grade to 12th grade
'cause I didn't wanna do
that bullshit homework
that meant nothing in real fucking life.
(cheering and applauding)
The problem is, that
shit ended when I was 18,
you've got the rest of your life.
Which gets me back to this.
This thing freaks me out
so much, you can't imagine,
because the one thing this
thing is is actual opportunity
that our grandparents didn't grow up with.
This thing allows you
to still be practical
and maintain the job that you hate
so you can pay off your student
loans and your mortgage,
but create your side hustle on here
around the shit that you actually love,
whether that's the fucking Chicago Bears,
whether that's fucking sneakers,
whether that's doing comedy skits,
whether that's reincarnating the formula
that your grandmother had
for soup from your country
that you're now gonna
sell direct to consumer
on the back of Uber Eats.
I don't give a fuck what
ridiculous thing comes out
of your mouth, this thing,
if you make content on it
and understand where people
actually pay attention,
actually gives you a
prayer for that to happen,
as long as you do a couple of core things,
and that's what I'm gonna talk about.
Core thing number one,
the single biggest thing,
in my opinion, that the
majority of these people
in this room are doing wrong.
This is number one.
I believe that 98% of the
people in this arena right now
buy too much dumb shit.
I have become crazy fascinated,
as I've lived my life,
I'm trying to understand
why the fuck so many
of my parent's immigrant's
friends, other immigrants,
and just immigrants in general,
have a disproportionate
success rate in the framework
of America, and I finally figured it out.
They're not smarter,
it's not even necessarily
that they work harder.
It's that they come to America
and they buy nothing stupid
for 15 fucking years.
They just live like shit,
buy nothing, save money,
buy a business, and move on.
The level of insecurity that
is permeating this country
so that people end up buying
cars and houses and clothes
that they can't afford to impress people
that they don't even like
is the great epidemic
in our society.
(cheering and applauding)
I get to say this from truth.
I lived my 20s, all my
20s, 22 to 29, my 20s,
in a shitty fucking apartment
in Springfield, New Jersey.
I didn't buy any fucking clothes,
I didn't have swag fucking sneakers,
I went on no fucking vacations,
I just fucking worked and saved money,
and I was building a
business for my parents,
not even for myself,
so when I tell people to be patient,
it's easy 'cause I lived it.
I don't stand up here
ever talking about shit
that I didn't actually do first.
And so, if you're not pumped,
if you're not like loving life,
before you try to figure
out the hook or the secret,
or if you think Tony's gonna
re-jigger your fucking brain,
or I'm gonna give you some fucking secret
to do on fucking Instagram
that's gonna change everything,
before you think about that,
go home and look at your
fucking credit card bill
and stop buying dumb shit.
(cheering and applauding)
Because when you don't buy dumb shit,
that money stays in the fucking bank
and you can do something
with your fucking life.
Instead of having a new
pair of fucking Off-Whites.
Who the fuck are you flossing for?
Fuck!
(laughing)
Fuck, Chicago!
(cheering and applauding)
You think somebody's gonna like you better
'cause you fucking got
a new Audi, you dick.
Jesus.
And that is what is most
interesting about this place,
because if you wanna look at
this place in a negative way,
it's super easy,
'cause everybody's fucking
fake life-ing on Instagram.
You know how many people
here are gonna go hiking
this weekend for the
fucking stupid picture?
They don't wanna go hiking,
they just wanna get a couple
more likes on Instagram.
I know people who jump
the fence, at night,
at private plane airports, to take a photo
to make pretend they fly private.
Do you fucking understand what's going on?
And then it gets deeper.
There are people in bullshit
relationships, right now,
posting photos of themselves on vacation
acting like they're fucking happy.
My friends, this is a manifesto
in Chicago this morning
about executing on truths.
(spits) That shit.
And let me give you very basic truths,
if you spend money on shit you don't need,
you're gonna lose.
If you buy those things
to impress other people,
you've already lost.
You need to take a step
back and understand
what you're doing.
This is not a conversation
today about making more money.
Success means being happy,
not how much money you have.
We are in the middle stages
of mental unhappiness,
mental issues in our country,
predicated on a lot of different things,
not paying the piper in
2009 like we should've,
we should just be getting
out of a depression.
But we all got bailed
out, let's start there.
On the greatest generation
of funny parenting
I've ever seen in my life.
My favorite thing going
on in the world right now
is 40 to 60 year olds
shitting on millennials
when they were the fuckers
that raised those people.
(cheering and applauding)
That's my favorite shit.
These kids are so soft, no shit, dick,
you gave them an eighth place trophy.
(laughing and cheering)
These kids don't take feedback well.
No shit, dick, when their
teacher yelled at them,
you ran to the school and
fucking fought like an asshole.
Fuck, that pisses me off.
Guys, let kids lose.
Let's actually talk about losing.
Micro losing is the greatest shit.
I stand here in front of you today
because the first 18 years of my life,
the world told me I sucked,
and I lost at everything.
I sucked at school, I wasn't
big enough for sports,
everything fucking sucked.
- [Man] Yeah!
- That's right, bro.
(laughing)
But we're fucking here now!
(cheering)
And we're here now because a
singular person in my life,
my mother, instilled such
disproportionate self-esteem
in me without creating entitlement.
When I was nice to people,
she fucking praised the shit
out of it.
When I struck out in a game,
she didn't make pretend
some shit was rigged,
she said the pitcher was
better than you, dick.
(laughing)
The fine line, how many people here
have consumed my content?
(cheering)
I'm gonna give you a
secret I've never said,
all I am is the puppet and the byproduct
of Tamara Vaynerchuk.
What I'm trying to do for
you is what she did for me.
What Tamara, my mom,
Vaynerchuk, that's what I said,
did for me was she
positively and optimistically
gave me a framework of the world,
but she didn't create entitlement,
because when I lost, I
lost and when I won, I won.
And so when you look at my content,
you can see certain times when it feels
fucking a little rough and a little edgy,
and other times when it's warm and fuzzy.
It's because both exist,
and everybody thinks
you have to pick sides.
It's like the bullshit
in our country right now,
people think you have to pick sides.
It fucking makes no sense,
the reality is this,
just like in our country,
we're just one human.
Life is binary in that
some things are soft
and some things are hard.
And the reality is, some
things are very basic,
and here they are.
I believe the following,
that we are so blessed
to be in this room because
for the first time in my life,
I think it's practical, not ideological,
to actually build a
business around the things
you actually like to
do, which will then mean
that you'll actually
work the 13 hours a day,
if you wanna make a million
dollars a year, that it requires
because there is no
fucking passive income.
Do you understand?
You can make a good
investment, I understand,
but when you buy 30 homes properly
and you think it's passive,
what about when the tornado comes?
What about when the fucking
person that manages it quits?
What about when somebody lights
the fucking house on fire?
The amount of money you
make is wildly correlated
to the amount of anxiety and
stress you're able to carry.
(cheering)
People want it easy out here.
There is no easy if you
want to live a 1% life.
People are so funny in
the audacity of the words
that come out of their mouth.
My friends, the top 1% earners in America,
one of the richest countries in the world,
start at $420,000 a year.
If you're in this room and
you make $420,000 a year,
that means you make in the
top 1% in this country.
Yet, everybody's walking around like
if you don't make a milli,
you haven't even started.
We're delusional, and all
the people that make 420
and above, they work their dick off.
Guys, they work.
Like, it's so much work, it takes work.
Now, what I believe is, what
absolutely just drives me
so happy and why I wanna be here is
I can't believe that you can
actually make funny videos
on Instagram and get
brands to pay you $10,000
for you to hold a bottle
of Pepsi in your hand.
I mean, it's crazy.
What's crazy is you can literally
go start a Shopify store
and sell T-shirts or makeup or bow ties
'cause your grandfather wore
bow ties, and you design it,
on the internet and it gets
shipped to you from China,
and then you run Instagram ads.
The level of, guys, if this
existed when I was a kid,
fuck college, I wouldn't
have graduated high school.
I'm not sure I would've made it through
fucking middle school.
(laughing)
This is a mindset and execution game.
You have to understand how
ridiculously good it is,
and I believe that's
very hard when there's
so much negativity being
pushed on social media,
on mainstream media,
everybody's trying to
convince you it's bad,
it's the greatest.
It's the greatest, the
problem is everybody can do it
and supply and demand then kicks in.
Everybody can sell bow ties,
everybody can make funny videos,
everybody can show off their
abs and get the right angle
on their fucking ass, and all that shit.
Everybody can do that.
But it doesn't mean
that you shouldn't try.
And more importantly,
and I what I really wanna
leave you with is something
you really need to understand,
which is almost everybody fails
because of their intentions.
Almost everybody fails
They start businesses for themselves.
Makes sense, we're humans.
But everything that
runs through their mind
is what's in it for me?
How do I maximize my profit?
What's it gonna be like for me?
How is it gonna be good for me?
The only way to succeed
in the world we live in
is to actually be consumer centric.
There's a very specific
reason that Amazon is winning.
It's because everything
that happens at that company
is trying to figure out
how it's good for you.
It's good for you to buy Prime
because you love the fact
that, all year, that
means everything you buy
has free shipping, that's good for you.
It comes quick 'cause that's good for you
'cause you value time.
The singular reason that
my content has worked,
whether it was wine for the
first six years of my career,
or it's been business
over the last eight years,
has worked is because before
I post any piece of content,
in my mind I think about how
is this gonna be valuable
to you?
How is this singular piece
of content going to bring
any value to you?
The single reason I've been
able to build an audience
is I don't put out content
that's a top-of-the-funnel
piece of content that
gets you into my database
so I can sell you my product.
It's a piece of content that
I hope brings you value,
which then creates a relationship with us,
the end, period, the end.
And so if you're taking
anything from this talk,
number one, the opportunity is ridiculous.
I need you to understand that.
If you don't know what
Shopify is, Google it
and learn about the
platform that costs nothing
to start a store on the
internet, that works really well,
and sell something on it.
If you don't know how to
run an Instagram Story ad,
like I referenced it earlier,
you wrote a note about it but
I didn't get to the detail.
The reason I didn't get to the detail
is 'cause the details
are called Google.com.
Go to fucking Google.com,
type in how do I run
an Instagram ad, enter, and
8,000 trillion fucking billion
results come back.
Everybody wants people to come up here
and fucking draw shit on
a fucking white paper.
Are you out of your
fucking mind? It's 2019!
Information is a commodity,
information is zero.
It doesn't cost anything,
don't buy information.
The internet, it's free.
Take a step back and
understand what you're doing
with yourself, what makes you happy?
Are you trying to be rich
because you wanna stick it
to your parents or
everybody else that said
that you couldn't?
Or are you trying to do something
'cause you actually like it?
Are you trying to be rich
because you wanna go buy shit
to create a perception that you're happy?
Or do you actually want to be happy?
We live in remarkable times.
The internet is the single
greatest and most complex
and ridiculous invention in
the history of the human being.
We, luckily for some unknown reason,
happen to be living during
the era of it finally hitting
it's scale, 30 years in,
and it is in it's prime opportunity.
The comp I would make is
imagine we were living
in Chicago hundreds and
hundreds of years ago,
and we could be buying up
property for almost nothing
because we just didn't understand what
was actually happening,
that's how I think about
attention on the internet today.
It is so valuable and
it is so underpriced,
and literally, the only
thing that's stopping you
is insecurity.
The reason you're not
posting is you're worried
that nobody's gonna care
what you have to say.
The reason you're not posting
is you don't like the way
you look in the picture or the camera.
All these different
things that come down to
what other people think, not
what you think about yourself.
The reason, my man over
there, I was clapping
and I love talking about losing
for the first 18 years of my life
is 'cause it was easier shit
because I didn't give a
fuck what you had to say.
I was in my own cocoon,
doing my own thing,
making my own self happy,
and I stand here today in
the same God damn place.
Do I want my content to do well? Sure.
Do I want my businesses
to be successful? Yep.
Do I want Empathy Wine to do well? Sure.
And the sneaker, do I want, of course,
like, I'm playing, I'm playing my game,
I want to win, I'm playing my game.
But when I lose, I'm grateful
for the opportunity to play.
(cheering and applauding)
What I learned about myself at a young age
was that, I see it, I gotta
leave with this though.
I recently realized, oh shit,
this is all working because
when I was five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 10, 11, 12, 13,
when it was a summer day
in the '80s in Jersey,
and everybody went out to
play, play hoop, whatever,
I wanted to work.
I rang doorbells and washed people's cars.
I sold lemonade, baseball cards exploded
and I started buying
them and flipping them.
Then I turned 14 and wanted to
work at my dad's liquor store
for 14 hours a day for two bucks an hour,
because I realized work was
my passion, I like the game.
It's why athletes, being in this stadium,
athletes that love their
game, a lot of athletes don't,
as I've gotten to know athletes,
they do it 'cause that's
where the money is,
but they're not happy, they don't love it.
It blows a lot of our minds
'cause we'd love to play
in the fucking league, but
not everybody wants that.
This is one big game of happiness
and the internet allows you to,
but are you patient enough?
And are you secure and
have enough self-esteem
to go through the process
of eating the fucking dirt
to get to a place of happiness?
Success, my friends, needs
to stop being talked about
how much money you have,
it needs to be talked about
how many fucking smiles
you put on your face.
(cheering and applauding)
It does.
And I love the cliche shit, motherfuckers,
I know you're in the crowd right now,
they're like, easy for
you, dick, you have money.
Motherfucker, I was happy before I had it,
you didn't know me, dick.
(cheering and applauding)
You didn't know me.
You didn't know me and I
don't necessarily know you,
but I know this, because I
read 10,000 fucking comments
a day in my DM,
we have a ridiculous opportunity,
you just need to see it.
Please try to build a
business around the thing
that you would do if you
weren't getting paid for it,
because it's the only thing
that you're gonna work
hard enough at, 'cause
you actually like it.
Go flip Thomas the trains on eBay,
start a blog about fucking Smurfs,
start about a podcast
about reviewing whiskeys
or the '85 Bears.
My man, you could start a
podcast and an Instagram account
and a YouTube show
about just the '85 Bears
and get $100,000 in sponsorship,
from car dealerships, and pizza shops,
and all sorts of shit in this town,
and to me, the fact that that's true
and so many of those same
people are making 87,000
being a lawyer or 90,000 being
an executive and hating life,
or let me just play with this
and I'm gonna leave with this,
would you really rather make
212,000 a year and be unhappy,
or make 97,000 and do the
thing that you love the most?
And the only thing you have to do
is live a little more
humbly, just a little.
We have to fucking talk
about this, that's the game,
that's the game.
Please, wake up, I love you Chicago.
(cheering and applauding)
Wake up Chicago!
- Come on, guys.
- What up, dog?
I see you back there, I see you up there!